Hello everybody, hello, hello, and Drago, thank you so much
for the tour and he gives a thank you.
Hello, hello, hello.
Welcome in!
Howdy, it's Dino time!
Go!
With my arms up.
Mubikor, thank you for the gifted!
Gau!
Minto soar!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha We...
We will build the world's greatest Jurassic Park, maybe.
There might be accidents.
We'll see.
If you guys like how I did the subtitles as classic anime
subtitle yellow, I mean, though, Ghostsaurus Rex.
This way, your initials are MG.
Oh, MG Rex!
Metal Gear Rex.
The Mintoaurus Rex is very...
very dangerous i can smell your fear i can smell you i can
see everything if you're still if you're moving i have x-ray
vision i can see through your clothes might want to get that
checked out
can't think of a better way to spend an afternoon stuck in
bed sick than listening to mint good Feel better.
No.
Thank you for the super top.
Feel better.
When did your love of dino start?
Was it the ride or just the love of dino's all kids have
that you never grew out of?
If it's the latter, same.
You know, it's kind of funny because, like, I didn't go
through a super dinosaur phase.
I went through an Egypt phase.
But, I've always had an interest in dynos.
Hmm.
And, I don't know what it was.
I think, like, it just kept growing.
I feel like I, I, I don't know.
Like, I would be like, yeah, dynos are cool.
I always love dynos.
But, like, now I feel like I've gotten really into them more
than I have before.
This should be a great time.
You're a clever girl after all.
I love Jurassic Park.
It's one of those movies that I feel like I watch almost
every time I'm on a plane.
Like a long plane ride I put on Jurassic Park.
Nightmare Grimm.
Welcome to a membership.
Thank you.
Dinosaur.
Because I am a fossil.
You feel good about that one?
You say I like dinosaurs because I'm a fossil?
You feel like a winner with that?
You think that was a swinging hit?
If you like Egypt, Time Lapse is a neat old point and click
puzzle game with an Egyptian section.
Uh-oh.
Well, I don't regret it.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm not a fossil because I'm ectoplasm.
That's like the opposite.
Fossils are hard and maybe brittle, depending on how they
are.
And I am not.
I'm goopy.
Do you ever watch Lamba Before Time?
Yes!
Yep, yep, yep.
I watched the lamb before time.
Rinse, thanks.
Happy birthday.
I was wondering if you could cast me a good luck magic spell
for my upcoming dance performance.
More, more.
Good luck.
Be me.
What is my favorite?
favorite dinosaur.
Ankylosaurus.
Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed.
I like that guy.
He's played Age of Mythology.
That'd be neat for him.
Egypt lover.
You know, I only played the Age of Empires.
I did not play Age of Age of Mythology.
Not Iguanadan.
Believe it or not, Iguanadan is not my favorite.
Believe it or not.
I have like a, I actually have like a model kit of Anky Anky
and Joyer?
Yeah, an Anky What is, that's so Anky
Aoe Pro?
Definitely not a pro.
Age of Mythology.
That sounds, maybe we could try it though.
Aguanidons and Shambles?
Yeah, they are because the ride, I think the one ride that
we'll ever see ever that features an iguanodon is gone
iguana gone uh every i feel i fear every other dinosaur ride
you're gonna get what triceratops stegosaurus t-rex
obviously but that's what i loved about the dinosaur ride
you got some dinosaurs that were not as popular i i learned
that the dinosaur uh the carnatoris is what used for that
movie the dinosaur movie apparently it's because jurassic
park was in its heyday around the time and when they made
the movie they were like we don't want to copy jurassic park
and do a t-rex so we're gonna go with the carnatoris instead
i like the carnator yeah the oversized carno yeah he's much
bigger no he has a special name it's like carnatoris florida
Oridius or something.
He was created especially for a dinosaur.
He's actually supposed to be a little guy.
He's supposed to be teeny tiny.
Not teeny tiny, but you know.
Yeah.
But today we're playing Jurassic Park.
Jurassic World Evolution.
I did talk about this game before on stream.
And I was questioning whether I should play it or not.
But, I read some more reviews and people were saying that
it's really, really good.
So, I'm excited to get into it.
I've never played any of the other Jurassic World games,
Jurassic World Evolution games.
So, I'm very excited.
Oh, Quinn!
Happy birthday!
It was my birthday yesterday and it was the first time I
ever said to Super Chat that was also to you.
I hope you have a great night.
You too!
I hope you had a wonderful, wonderful, wonderful, wonderful,
wonderful, excellent, amazing birthday!
Can't wait to see the Kettle Koalas.
V2!
Me too!
Today the news would like to know, what kind of dino are
you?
Yes, we know your secret.
We know what's behind the V-Tuber.
There is nothing!
What?
I'm no dino.
Are you caught?
This isn't another old joke.
Jurassic World Evolution is kind of a mouthful to say.
It is.
J-W-E.
We're playing J-W.
Boomer Dino.
J-W.
Jwee 3.
Ever thought of playing Dino Crisis?
By the way, hi, Minto.
Hi, Eric!
I have thought of playing Time Crisis, but Dino Crisis might
be fun too.
Excited for your cons, Armito.
Since you're on a Dino kick, I'd recommend Nigel Marvin's
Prehistory Shows.
They're pretty outdated, but it's made up for the charm of a
British naturalist excitedly talking at CGI dinosaurs.
I do love silliness.
Sandbox is great.
Campaign really holds your hand.
I heard that, too, that it was a...
like super like i don't know i don't know what i wanted to
be a campaign or sandbox excited to see you play this if you
like this one you may be interested in prehistoric kingdom
it's still in early access but it looks like it's turning
out really awesome oh thank you deliran thank you this one
has all the good qo qo l stuff already that's why that's
also why i i chose this one instead of two a lot of people's
reviews were saying like oh this could this game could have
been a dlc for for domestic world evolution too but i i felt
looking into it a little bit more you know how sometimes
people will say that about a game like this could have been
a dlc to the first one but maybe they don't realize that
like some things were kind of rebuilt you know what i mean
like like not everything could be a dlc Sometimes games have
to be like, you know, like reprogrammed and things like
that.
Yeah, updated systems.
Yeah, yeah, a different engine.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
So, what?
Oh, what was it that?
Oh, there was a game, I feel.
That.
Oh, it wasn't a game.
No, um.
This happened, well, it's kind of different, but like...
Oh, sorry, I'm talking about Miraculous Ladybug again.
But Miraculous Ladybug in the first couple of seasons looked
very different from how Miraculous Ladybug looks now.
And people kind of toss back and forth between which
animation style they like.
Not the Brazil DLC.
But they kind of talk about how they like the previous, or,
you know, some people like the new animation, some people
like the previous animation.
And you'll have the people that like the older animation to
be like, why did they have to change it, why, why?
And it's literally because the animation program that they
used, like, I don't remember if it got discontinued or if it
updated or something.
But they literally can't go back to the old style.
because um because it doesn't exist anymore yeah so it's
kind of you know they had to switch to unreal is that what
it was since dinosaurs had feathers have you ever wondered
if they were all puffy like owls and feathers didn't get
preserved like their skeletons I do wonder that right hmm
Ladybug season 3 could have been DLC So true And now that
Adobe anime was also going to be shut down Oh they
backtracked I heard about it getting shut down But I didn't
know That it backtracked Are you a new dino look denier?
No In fact I really like that I think it's really cool that
more technology comes out where we are able to get step by
step more and more accurate, potentially accurate
representations.
I think it's so cool.
Oh, and also, I mean, people have been saying that like
birds are descendants of dinosaurs forever, you know?
So it makes sense if they had feathers before.
Perhaps that's also why we can't at Sonic games, like
Unleash Your Generations anymore.
Who knows?
They are mini dinos.
Birds are so cute.
Birds aren't real, Minto.
They are.
They are in my heart.
Please.
To be more precise, birds are dinosaurs.
Yes.
Birds are dinosaurs.
But like...
What does that make like pterosaurs then?
I think about it because I'm like, you know, T-Rex can't
fly.
So it's just big birds.
But like, did they evolve from dinosaurs or terrors?
You know what I mean?
Like, I'm just like, I don't really know.
prove you're not a dinosaur we need to hear your best
attempt at a dinosaur cry oh actually you know what i love
actually i've one of my favorite overhaul or i guess like
you know the type the t-rex the like the the Jurassic Park
t-rex roar that you hear is not accurate you know how like
they've come to learn or i guess
deduced, hypothesized that that T-Rexes did not, did not
roar like they do in the movies.
No, no.
But the fact that they click, which is even scarier, they
kind of like, so scary.
Nothing in Jurassic Park is accurate.
Yeah, well, you know, a lot of people.
It's still like people's, when they think of a T-Rex, it's
like the T-Rex they think of.
you know so okay but let's i don't i didn't accept any of
this yet because i didn't know let's accept let's see
oh oh it just takes me to the main menu i thought it was
gonna be like a cutscene or something um
i still don't know if i want to i feel like campaign would
be fine to get me used to the controls, no?
So I'm okay, but...
Also...
I want to create my own stuff.
I don't want them to be like, okay, now put this guy in
there, you know?
Does that mean T-Rexes are just bigger shoebill?
Oh, I need DMCA risk!
Oh my gosh, you guys, I need your opinion.
Okay, there is a streaming mode, right?
Mute, licensed music.
I have it on currently.
What?
I want to hear Jurassic Park theme!
What if I do it instead?
I don't remember, wait.
I wonder if it's playing it right now.
We're just missing it.
Will the Sandbox have a tutorial, I wonder?
Challenge.
Test your paleo-curation skills against a set of unique
challenges.
Oh, this version's way better.
You need a tutorial.
No, I agree.
I want a tutorial.
If I remember correctly, it does not.
Okay, we'll go to campaign then.
Maybe we do campaign today, and then whenever we come back
to Jui 3, we do a sandbox.
Life finds a way.
Genetic power.
It's him!
The most awesome force that the planet has ever seen.
With it, we diverted the very...
course of natural history we took something so far away in
time gold bloom and put it on display for the world to see
that's crazy they actually got him or worse or worse
sometimes though it really was a a compelling vision of
coexist moving in slow motion precious brief glimpses of
peace the non-streamer mod is instant Oh, boat is instant
DMCA.
No!
But when nature seemed to offer a correction, many people
saw only a tragedy.
Greed saved the dinosaurs from the volcano.
Oh, I forgot to do.
Oh, I forgot to do it.
But it was compassion.
That's my God.
Oh, with the horse.
What the horse doing there?
To spread into every corner of the planet.
Free him.
We need to find a way to coexist but can we put our hubris
aside and work with nature this time this time can we
finally allow life to find a way oh look at the little fear
he said the thing he said the thing he said the
It took me a second.
He said it.
We're in the Badlands.
Oh, yeah.
The Dinosaur Integration Network is hoping to gather support
of their goal of helping dinosaurs worldwide.
This historic patch of Badlands will be a showcase of what
the D-I-N-D.
Dinner.
Yummy.
You can't see it, but there's like a little loading dinosaur
right behind me.
chasing a goat.
If there's one thing that the history of evolution has
taught us, it's that life life will not be contained.
The game is not lagging.
I'm lagging.
Snake water.
Look how cute they are though.
Time and time again.
Tearing down barrier after barrier until finally...
Breaking bad plus dinosaur might be the best thing ever this
Jurassic world there is no path left to travel shaft tilt
finds away no viable option but coexistence with the
dinosaurs it's a rocky road ahead of us less rocky perhaps
under the right management oh my god they're so cute
Welcome!
I am, of course, Cabot Finch.
Cabot Finch!
I might have to change some settings, guys, so I'd stop
lagging, so...
Any owner of this lovely patch of Badlands?
Go on!
Take a look around!
Breathe in the, uh... fresh hair!
Hmm.
Decidedly less, uh, less fresh around the herbivore
enclosure.
Hey, tell me, what are you calling this again?
Is it done?
Dim?
Din.
The dinosaur integration network.
I am Kira Chang.
A pleasure to meet you.
We intend to help dinosaurs and humans coexist globally.
And I am here to find clients who share that goal.
Hey, so I should, um, what, ignore the roaming velociraptors
that I saw on the way in and, and just focus on the bare
bones and closure?
Oh, is that okay?
Wow.
You're spoiling me.
at the site map.
Okay, one second.
I have an idea.
Everybody say goodbye to the Minto as you know.
Say goodbye.
Pew!
TV Minto!
TV Rinto is here to save the day!
Wait, am I...
I'm still lagging.
Oh, no!
Wait.
Uh...
Fine.
I think I am.
I'm gonna have to reduce the resolution.
Wait, actually, what is the resolution?
Oh, it won't let me.
What do I do, V-Sync on?
It won't let me change the frame rate.
You guys saw it was...
It was...
It's okay now, though.
We're all good.
Everything's fine.
I don't need to change it.
I know that, like, playing in window mode is not as good,
but for my setup, I...
I don't know, I just, I don't like, I don't like playing
full screen.
Search for a dino hoodie asset for TB models, I know!
But this is all, do whatever, we got it working.
Where are the velociraptors?
Okay, so what am I doing?
Open the site map.
Baby!
Oh my god, I can hear them stepping!
Wait, how do I get out of you?
Oh, okay.
So cute.
Nobody's even looking at them.
Nobody's stopping and being so enthralled.
Oh, there they go.
Yes, yes, go into the viewing gallery.
Yes, yes!
Yes!
Viewing gallery one.
Okay, site map.
I'm gonna press M.
Okay, that worked.
Not only does this map allow us to oversee the site, But it
also shows that the Raptors are no longer nearby.
Good!
We have plenty of time.
Oh, yes.
Plenty.
Plenty of time.
Until, of course, uh, we don't.
Yeah.
All right.
Let's get this showcase underway.
I'm looking at what everything means.
Okay.
There's my Dippy.
My Diplodocus.
He's happy.
Oh.
Oh, she.
I'm so sorry.
Dippy.
I will tell you guys, I'm so bad at...
As I am bad with names of anything, I am bad with names of
dinosaurs, so I'll do my best.
I see dinosaur.
I know dinosaur.
Usually.
Sometimes.
Yeah, I say usually.
Not really.
But, you know what I mean.
But...
Okay.
To kick things off, some rescues will be arriving here any
time now.
Of who?
Let's use a delivery zone to transport them all in one trip.
Okay.
It saves time, and...
Big Lizard.
Even better, a boatload of chopper fuel.
Oh, there's a chopper.
Capture team standing by.
How do I...
Can I change, like, the...
I feel like I'm very top-down.
Prepare for delivery.
Oh, this thing.
Enclosures.
Oh, delivery's out.
Oh!
Place in the highlighted area.
Don't I want an area for...
Is there highlighted?
Is this the...
Is this the area that we shall put...
Oh, right here, right here!
Ah!
Okay.
That is a highlighted area.
Okay, perfect!
When the chopper gets here, direct them to that delivery
zone.
Loki serotops imminent.
Get in here.
Oh,
transport Dinah's- six of them?
Place the delivery zone.
Excellent.
The Loki serotypes are on their way.
And the pilot said there's something special about the
group.
So, uh, consider my interest, Pete.
Oh, look, look.
Our other important guest has arrived.
Dr. Dua, welcome to Montana.
And thank you for inviting me.
There's all these people.
Your goal to help dinosaurs thrive has certainly caught the
conservation sector's attention.
I truly hope you can succeed.
Ha, so do I.
Uh, so do I.
Release them.
Oh!
Oh my god, we get...
A wild juvenile dinosaur.
Little baby.
Absolutely remarkable.
And not, not a common sight those days.
You know, the mind boggles thinking about how its
experiences now will shape it.
Will its future be peaceful?
Oh my god, Jeff Goldblum is in the corner!
Deciding factor, I suspect, is you.
Four environmental issues.
Can we perhaps observe it more closely?
I'm I'm cool.
I'm in look it That is so cute It's so Jeff is in the chat
Dinosaur appeal is one of the things that'll draw new guests
to a site there is so much boy to juvenile sell entry
tickets Why did they call them juveniles called the babies?
It's just a baby.
That's a capybara
Wow, select the territory tab and the dinosaur...
What is going on?
What's happening now?
As dinosaurs explore their new enclosure, they'll form a
territory.
It's inside this territory that their environment must meet
their needs.
Some dinosaurs play well with others.
Some... less so.
Keep an eye on who's sharing an enclosure with who.
Okay.
There's already six guys in here, though.
That's a lot, no.
Oh, the horn, the capybara.
Right, select the comfort tab.
There is so much stuff going on here.
Holy cow.
I must say, that enclosure is a far cry from the environment
these animals are most for.
They hate it.
All part of the demonstration, I assure you.
We have a suite of environmental tools to help make this
enclosure more appropriate, which is, of course, our next
priority.
Yes.
Yes, it is.
Okay, so they love...
Some plant fiber plants baby.
Oh, yeah You know My favorite thing or one of my favorite
things about the This is a zoo tycoon pretty yeah, I think
of a zoo tycoon is when you add is when you add things that
the animals like They'll be like oh, and then when you put
things they don't like they go
We need calamites Oh, oh, big trees, big trees.
Does, do we need to go outside of the range?
What is this?
No.
Psychad?
Oh, wow!
Whoa, whoa!
Oh, meh.
Let him in!
I don't even know if he's match.
Oh, my dinosaurs attack.
Oh.
Need that fiber for dino drop-ins.
Oh yeah, baby.
Non-native forest.
What is this?
Oh, woodland.
Oh, woodland!
It looks so nice!
Wonderful work.
Actions like this will certainly earn you a good reputation
with the conservation sector.
Hey, thanks.
It kind of looks all over the place.
Kind of looks like a mess.
Oh, okay.
We're done.
You get five habitats in one.
Uh-oh.
Not to alarm you all, but is that a sandstorm?
Oh, no!
And it came out of nowhere.
Typical.
They don't care.
It ripped apart some of our fences, too.
Storms like this can harm or panic dinosaurs.
This is a delicate situation.
Oh, wait a second.
Our fences are so weak that a...
sandstorm right direct control the giant is a big threat to
our guests the priority needs to be tranquilizing it with
the capture team chopper we can repair the enclosure later
okay here i go wait i get to drive the plane i get to fly
and i i get to fly the helicopter wait here i go oh oh my
god i really do uh ascend
Oh my god!
Uh, aim!
I'm aiming.
Uh, I am trying to aim.
Shoot!
Aim mode.
Oh, oh, there we go!
Oh, no!
Please!
Uh, I think there was a drop.
Shot missed.
There was a bit of a drop off.
Oh, go to sleep.
They're just chilling.
I don't need them.
Why are the, why is it okay for the Velociraptors to run
around, but not these guys?
Hello?
Okay.
These people don't care.
There's people still walking around.
They don't care at all.
They don't care.
Look.
Everyone's chill.
Sandstorm gone.
Everything's fine.
Good job, team.
Because they're too big.
Oh, um, oh, look at, look at the guy, he's sitting outside
the helicopter, that's so cute.
Let's go back home.
Exit, exit the capture team helicopter.
I can take a photo?
Oh, wait, this is so fun!
Where'd they go?
Where are they?
Oh, sleepy guys right there.
They do be napping.
Look at that tail.
Say cheese.
Get money?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
What's Q in here?
Exit to go back to default.
You can't have a functioning park without the right
infrastructure.
And without a functioning park, where would we be?
What, sitting at home?
home uh not teetering on the edge of chaos boy wouldn't that
be wouldn't that be dull hey nice shooting those dinosaurs
won't be waking up anytime soon so you've earned us some
breathing space now i'm not exactly a death with a hammer so
let's bring in the experts we need a maintenance facility
and like yesterday
Look at those, look at the size of the feet!
This guy kind of landed a little haphazardly.
I'm so sorry.
He's snoring even.
I'm in here.
Hey, just a sleepy, sleepy guy.
Maintenance facility.
How much money do I even have?
Oh, oh, I'm so sorry.
A place in the highlighted area.
Not allowed.
Every facility place will need to be connected.
to our path network oh like that's why it was connected here
connect to the path oh never mind i make the path let's go
let's do a rock biome standard path very cool where's my
money at oh it's down okay i'm blocking okay hold on i'm
gonna move myself a little bit i'm gonna move like right
here i think then you guys will be able to see every
Or...
Up here...
Yeah, I'm gonna do this.
Here.
Wait.
There we go.
I think that works better, actually.
I'm right here, I'm right below you guys.
Floating head.
Yeah, okay, we gotta do our path.
Where do I connect it to?
Oh, oh!
Undo?
Now get out there and repair everything you can.
It looks kind of funky.
Looks kind of silly.
But it shouldn't be a path that looks like they can go on,
you know what I mean?
Take direct... Oh, we get to do it again!
We're taking direct control.
where am i where am i going oh my god what this is crazy you
know dr dua dr malcolm your uh testimonials would really
make a difference we need the support of the conservation
sector if anyone will take us seriously and if they don't
dim is going down and taking what's left of my money
Whoa!
Sick air!
She brought me and the others to Jurassic Park.
I'm repairing.
You know, I could dig out the report that I made for him,
but I'd need to update some details.
Dino GTA.
Us and Oz and running and screaming, you know, that sort of
thing.
Whoa!
Oh, sick!
Let's focus on the task at hand for the moment.
Excuse me!
Coming through!
Excuse me, official Dino didn't business over here.
One more hole!
Oh yeah.
JTA, Jurassic Zip Auto!
Hold on though, we also get to take a photo here.
Oops.
my bed oh wait i forgot the faces over here here we go
a thorough and efficient batch of repairs impressive work
thank you now that the enclosure is fixed up we're safe to
transport the dinosaurs back into it repetition penalty i
mean i'm getting money so who cares wait let's go take some
pictures of these guys too
Excuse me!
Everybody dives like crazy.
I'm here on official business.
It's like stuttering a little bit.
I don't know if you guys see it.
Oh, babies, babies.
Yes.
Oh my gosh, this is so...
Oh!
Look at them hop!
Oh, they're hopping for some reason.
What are they doing?
That's it.
Crazy money!
With like the sunshine and everything.
We're just being little babies.
I'll take it from here.
Tell me some birthday!
It's my birthday today!
I just wanted to say I'm really looking forward to yours and
everyone else's performances this Friday.
And that way Amos are super duper proud of everything you've
been able to achieve!
Thank you!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Ensure that Dippy are safely enclosed.
How do I get them inside?
Use the transport tool.
Oh, can I just, like, pick them up?
How do I... What's the transport tool?
I think I missed that part of the... Oh, here we go.
Here we go, transport.
When transporting a dinosaur, first choose the animal you
want to move and then pick where to send it.
Oh, that's fun!
Okay, we got a little flare going.
And you?
That storm could have torn the park apart or hurt the
dinosaurs.
We got lucky.
I think the hurting the dinosaurs is the more important
thing.
I suggested we prepare for such a thing weeks ago.
and we did prepare didn't we mr finch well you know the
to-do list was pretty long and how is i don't know we'd be
hit by him put him up on a sign we can make him the new
mcdonald's bit of a long shot but uh dr malcolm any chance
you can ignore the whole breakout thing oh boy now you're
asking an awful lot of me okay maybe not ignore but focus on
how well we dealt with Well, can't blame a guy for trying,
huh?
It's too...
The dinosaur ragdoll physics is something I never thought I
needed.
Oh my god!
You're extracting him.
Mito's gonna be more of a menace.
Why?
Why do you mean by that?
Oh, they're awake again.
Good morning!
Are you sleepy?
Oh no, you're okay, you're okay.
Oh, whoa!
Oh, he's so cute.
Yeah, that's what my cat does when I let her outside.
She like rubs the grass.
I got a face on this guy.
Now how do I, okay, I use the transport tool and they're all
safe, so what's next?
You're good.
You're happy.
Yes, you're happy and you're good and you're happy But it
says one out of two, did anybody else escape or am I crazy?
What's this Fossils no fossils not built Oh, yeah, uh, oh,
it worked.
Okay, it was just a glitch.
It was just a glitch.
They'll let your maintenance ATVs patrol and fix the place
up automatically.
Oh, maintenance posts.
Maintenance ATV teams can be assigned to maintenance posts.
They can automatically repair, reboot, resupply, and inspect
buildings.
Whoa.
That seems handy.
All right.
You want your maintenance posts to cover all buildings and
power generators that might need repairing, refueling or
resupplying so like those posts also have a wider range to
them and any fences that break in that range will
automatically get repaired so nice oh mochi okay yeah we're
taking him home so this would cover like a bunch here and
then we could do over here well almost oh my gosh wait can
we fit this we might need to do like Hmm.
They actually got Jeff Goldblum back to voice in this.
I know!
It's kind of insane, I feel.
I'm like, whoa!
Okay, what if we do...
Also, there's like a fence that's not coming.
Okay, that's part of the tutorial.
Part of the tutorial.
Let's do it here.
Let's do...
here and we'll do we'll do three of them we'll do three
oh it okay assign a maintenance team once you've placed your
maintenance posts you can directly assign a maintenance team
to each one oh no team add team oh no I I have about three
but i only i only have two guys uh-oh i need to hire more
people task received maybe i should have put it on here they
can do multiple they can oh okay cool
okay that makes two of one okay okay for more dinosaurs team
two is over here and then these ones are closer they were
struggling in the nearby desert but we can give them a
better life here maybe it's okay one moment Corithosaurus.
They cohabitate wonderfully with Loki Ceratops.
Please do place them in the same enclosure.
Replicating natural varied ecosystems should always be a
high priority.
All right then.
You're the boss.
Until you say you're supporting us at least, then I'm back
in charge.
I'm kidding.
Mostly.
Give me two minutes.
Coritosaurus.
Where did he say that?
Who liked this guy?
Transport too.
Oh, a lucky serotops.
Deliver all dinosaurs.
This place is shaping up faster than I expected.
The benefit of hiring the right park manager, eh?
I'm a genius, I'm an actual.
Look at what you've done already.
This site is our very own window into prehistoric Montana.
Do you like it?
Diplodocus?
That's how you have Diplodocus.
Diplodocus.
I'm going to keep calling him Dippy.
Oh.
Whoa.
Love.
Why?
Why are they walking on top of each other?
Look at this guy laying down!
Oh, no.
Oh, those toes.
Dippy is a better name.
Like a platypus.
Yeah, like a platypus.
Open the container!
Okay.
Oh, oh, that's a tree.
This is the tree and my cousin.
Delivery successful!
Now, we better make sure those dinosaurs are loving their
new home.
I mean, I'm sure they are, but I pride myself on being a
good host.
Or at least a passable one.
They could certainly be more comfortable here.
Balancing comfort between multiple species can be a
challenge, but one worth overcoming.
Wow.
What an interesting pattern.
It's like a camouflage.
Well, you know.
You know what I mean.
Like a wartime-y camouflage pattern.
Not, I know.
Wow, the animal camouflages itself?
That's like crazy.
What do you like?
You like this leafy cloud.
Oh, and some brush land.
Alright, now's our chance to fix this exhibit, guys.
How do I...
Okay.
Ground leaf.
Is that what that means?
They want that.
Oh, no.
They don't like this.
It's noisy in here.
These guys are loud.
There we go.
make sure that they're okay are you are they oh are you guys
okay now they're so happy is it just me or do those
dinosaurs not look as happy as the loki seratops like many
species they need males in their herd to truly thrive male
dinosaurs are rather rare though So there's little you can
do.
Perhaps Din isn't a good fit for the conservation sector.
Your work is inspiring, but the dinosaurs need something
extraordinary if they're to get a foothold in the wild.
Maybe I should have done this area.
You know, the dinosaurs are adapting fast enough to
reproduce on their own.
The course of natural history is trying to reassert itself.
And you simply cannot fight nature.
But we could work with it.
know of a research station developing not only male dinosaur
synthesis but sustainable breeding programs too if it will
earn your support I suggest that we all head there
immediately oh they're so cute they run away from the car
coming back here right they blend in so well though no if
that research succeeds we have to return really is a good
camel male dinosaurs to these herds all right these gals
need some males these gals need a They want They want They
want the booty Open the world map Okay Map Oh This is the
world map Just kidding Oh We're going somewhere else
We're going to Hawaii
Let's go Let's go Welcome to membership Thank you Thank you.
Thank you.
Hawaii.
Oh, you can see it down.
See?
Isn't it so cute?
It's kind of messed up.
The most kawaii part of Hawaii.
Kawaii.
Whoa!
Well, you know, I've been to a tropical island harboring
so-called groundbreaking research before yeah we know and i
felt this same mix of sheer wonder and utter dread back then
too i'm more um optimistic about what i'll find this time
around but still if i if i may a word of advice yeah build
more places to hide than you think you need Very meta.
The fact that...
That poor guy is traumatized.
Aloha, Hawaii!
Aloha!
This is not a vacation, Mr. Finch.
We are here to support pioneering research on dinosaur
breeding.
And to that end, I'm pleased to introduce you all to Dr.
Luis Baldera, a leading paleoecologist.
Dr. Baldera, the room is yours.
Hey, good to meet you all.
Hello!
Truth be told, I...
wasn't expecting help so soon.
Kira seemed pretty insistent that it has to be now, though,
so I'm definitely going to make the most of it.
It's his bald era.
We're all dying to see how this works out.
Well, hopefully not literally dying.
My guy is so traumatized.
Dr. Valdea has done quite well on his own, but many minds
make light research.
Oh, babies.
We'll need a control center so that we can hire scientists
for the project.
Guys, they're so cute!
They're so cute!
No!
I can't hold back my tears!
They're so cute!
Oh my god.
Doth my eye- wait.
Do- Do my eyes deceive?
Is this who I think it is?
He's got the beak?
Is this the Aguadadan?
Oh, it's a Mayasora.
Dang, they look so similar.
So close.
It looks like him, though, doesn't it?
Place a control center in the marked area.
Okie dokie.
Where's the marked area?
Marked area.
We should hook that building up to the path network, too.
Classic luxury.
Oh, la la.
Oh, yeah, that's good.
That's fancy.
Science by candlelight is great for atmosphere, but less
great for productivity.
Why don't we have a generator down and power that building?
Generator.
Oh, wow.
Okay.
Oh.
Scientists have a variety of skills, but researching male
synthesis will require experience in genetics.
Please hire whoever you think can do the job.
Oh, there's a generator.
Just kidding.
Okay.
Hire a new scientist.
Alright.
Recruit.
We just have people.
Wait!
Oh my gosh, I wish I...
Why didn't they ask me?
Imagine my mug right there.
Like in there.
I'm like...
We just have straight up people.
four out of eight three out of eight generalist welfare
specialist oh increases all skills by wow they decreases
task time decreases task time by 20% okay so they have the
similar ones
did they say what kind I need to get Increase your
scientists.
Combine total genetic skills to two.
Recruit.
Oh, we need genetics.
Oh, Joyce has three.
You can't see, but she has three.
Uh-huh.
No one else.
Everyone, only Vincent has one.
So we would either have to get...
Can I like...
Oh, I can refresh.
Let's see who else we get.
It's expensive!
Never mind.
I think Joyce is our girl.
That's the genetic skill requirement sorted.
Scientists aren't free, so let's not hire more than we need
for now, huh?
The hell?
Don't laugh.
I'm going to hire everybody then.
People are expensive.
Apparently.
Okay.
Okay, first off, we're gonna need a science center.
See, while Parthenogenesis is a thing, it's, oh, that's
reproduction without a myth.
Dinosaur breeding typically requires a pair.
Male dinosaurs are uncommon in the wild, but we can create
our own with a bit of clever research.
So cute.
That's where the science center comes in.
Science center.
Woohoo!
Oh, I can choose its appearance even.
Oh, let's do the Jurassic Park one, rather than Jurassic
World.
You can... Oh, that's so fun!
Oh!
Wow!
Then we gotta path it, right?
We'll do the same fancy path.
Oh, oh, I like this.
There's, like, something so fun about, like, the
customization of, like, newer...
Uh...
Newer sim games like this.
Tycoon games like this.
Okay, research the following.
Male dinosaur synthesis.
Oh no.
Wait, you can make Indominus Rex!
Indoraptor?
What the hell?
What?
Angelo-dokus?
What the...
Scorpio Rex looks horrifying.
I know you guys can't see it very well, but...
Spina Seratops?
Kind of looks awesome, though.
Kittious.
Spine of Raptor!
Whoa, Stegoceratops!
It looks like a fairy.
She was a fairy.
Wait, what else can we research?
Attractions!
Aviary viewing gallery.
Dinosaur encounters!
Put me in, coach!
Guests.
Core guest building, small amenities.
Spino raptor.
Standard paths.
I'm just looking at everything before we do the gene stuff
Operation security camp surveillance camera dig sites
Whoa That's a boy
That's my guy.
I have to fuck him right now.
Can I?
That thing is so dumb looking.
Wait, but we can get the Plesiosaurus!
Oh.
Spinosaurus.
Insufficient skill.
We need more.
More!
Oh,
there's the iguana.
Wait, yeah, the iguanodons are in here.
Oh,
I guess it also, you know, oh my god, what the hell is that?
It's so scary.
I guess it's half Minto Day.
I hope I, I hope, I one, one day I hope I can find someone
who looks at me the way Mingo looks at kids like what is.
Oh, my guys are here!
Oh, yeah, baby!
Wait, this is a mayasora.
Mango.
Oh, gosh, he's the only one in there.
He's the only one!
He's the only reward that you need!
Oh my gosh.
My favorite part of this game is to go into first person
mode to see what my guests see.
You should try it once you get a bit more comfortable.
Yes!
What the heck is this?
This guy is so funky looking.
Sorry, I know chat is kind of blocking.
Here I'll move you guys over.
there you go look at him hold on look it's you it's you I'm
holding up my Ketzalcoat ah they're kissing my I have a
little Ketzalcoatless guy I got him first try and a gotcha
pawn I got him first try I have so I have him on my desk
it's your buddy i dropped him
oh so awesome oh he's so cool oh he's so awesome wow i can't
wait to see how big he is largest flying creature can't wait
yeah awesome
Yeah, he's a massive too, I bet, I bet he's so big.
Literally one of the coolest animals to ever live.
I agree.
Oh my gosh.
They're just, oh.
And they're terrifying.
They're so scary.
This guy is weird looking.
Whoa!
Oh, Karnataurus isn't here!
I'm the Tyranosaurus rex!
You gotta work for your T-Rex.
This guy looks like a dog.
Iconic T-Rex.
Trudon!
Velociraptor's in here too.
Weird looking dog.
Guys, doesn't he look like a dog?
Dimitrodon.
What the dog doing?
It's cool.
Learn more, guys.
Okay, sorry.
Research.
We're back.
This is not what we...
Enclosures!
Ooh!
Land hatchery!
Medicine.
Wait a second.
What was this?
Oh, the hybrids.
Wait, did you guys see these ones?
Is that Sheila's dog?
I love that skit so much!
Dementia dot is more closely related to us than dinosaurs!
That's funky.
I think we should all...
What if...
Okay, imagine you guys.
If we all started walking on all fours again...
You think we could start evolving to make that like our
prime mode of transportation of walking?
I thought the big fin looked like a potato chip.
We all started walking on all fours again.
Imagine how fast we would go.
We just started evolving back to...
Return to Monkey.
Yay!
Return to Monkey!
You start and let us know how it goes.
I'm already dead!
I can't further evolution!
You guys are alive!
You can do it!
Get us back to Monkey!
We can be so fast!
Can you imagine?
We're all running around on all fours everywhere?
If everybody starts doing it, the bodies would feel that it
is a necessary step in the evolution.
We just all have to agree to it.
We have to be a worldwide decision.
It has to...
It sounds logical.
It is how it works.
It's how it works.
People at the con's going to be very confused by the
crawling eyeballs.
Everybody has to commit to evolving on to use all fours.
No for me, dog.
No, please.
We would go so fast.
Don't you want to run next to the launches?
Umamusame!
Actually, it's kind of messed up that Uma Musume doesn't
have them running on all fours.
I used to run on all fours in high school, Chuni days.
Thanks for reminding me.
I saw a video the other day of a girl whose boyfriend was
chasing after their dog by running on all fours.
And he, like, ran up to her on all fours.
And she was just kind of like, ooh.
He was like, oh, you didn't...
Oh, she was like, why did you do that?
And he was like, oh, did I like that?
Me ick!
Everybody's booty's in the air.
She only pretended to be disgusted.
You think she was really into it?
Maybe.
I think that should be another Olympic sport.
You have running on two legs and then you have running on
all.
force.
We have, we can do it, we can include it in the next one.
I watched this one VTuber who said she used to jump around
on tables like Curious George and also said she would
pretend to be a werewolf.
Yeah, what a weird VTuber.
Yeah, funny taste.
I don't remember saying I pretended to be a werewolf.
Or are you talking about with my grandma when we would howl
at the moon?
I definitely dressed up as curious George once and jumped on
tables.
Minto's alt.
I think that counts, Minto.
Ow!
You know how it's so funny when you see, like, coyotes or,
like, like wolves and they're like howling but they don't do
like the like you know a regular like you when you expect a
wolf they go like oh
like they're just they're just yapping like what is bro
saying shut up okay let's research the let's research some
men oh we got a positive influence nice we're starting the
task it's costing us $500,000 to invent men.
Yeah, they just scream.
They're just...
Dr. Balgo, do you truly believe that this breeding program
will work?
I'm pretty sure it will.
Dinosaurs breeding in the wild is rare, but I've observed
common needs and behaviors.
Can I see your POV?
That's what we're building from.
Oh, it happened!
We've discovered men!
Right.
We need to gather some genetic material if we're going to
actually synthesize a male.
But finding an appropriate dig site will take a head for
logistics that I definitely don't have.
Let's hire some practical thinkers.
I like that word that we hire or we just we men come from
the M-Preg animal.
Skill tree unlocked.
Okay so what am I doing here?
Wait.
Hire scientists with a combined total logistic skill of
four.
Okay.
Logistic skill of four.
Recruit the where's oh logistics oh Vincent my man he's so
happy to be here now let's research a dig site with plenty
of myasora fossils myasora there's surely no better choice
to pioneer this research than a species whose name means
good mother lizard well sure what better reason to bring a
breathing thinking being into a strange new world than a
lovely apt name I love the good mother lizard wait so we
don't have mayasura then who is this we'll need an
expedition center to head to the base of operations for the
day I need to know let's construct one immediately oh here's
the expedition center to send dig teams to dig sites across
the world.
They'll return with fossils which contain genetic
information.
This is to create new dinosaurs.
Dig teams need scientists to lead them on the dig sites.
The digs themselves take time and money to complete.
The Science Center lets you extract dinosaur genome from
collected fossils.
Dig teams can also find valuable materials that can be sold
for cash money, baby.
Mommisaurus.
Alright, we're going on an expedition.
With a Center.
We could do Jurassic Park.
We could do... Oh, the DIN?
Oh, they have, like, a one.
Sorry.
That's so fun.
They have one for Jurassic World version, Jurassic Park
version, and the game.
Oh, that's fun.
I like how you can see what the generator, like, connects
to.
Whoa.
Oh, I gotta pass it.
I gotta pass it.
Fancy path.
Connected.
Oh, man.
No!
Let me redo it.
See, we send teams out to dig sites where they collect
fossils.
Then we crack those fossils open and scoop out the genome,
which lets us create dinosaurs.
Three different types of paths.
That wasn't the most scientific explanation, but it gets the
idea across, right?
Oh, look.
It's the Jurassic Park.
Look at his arms.
were found in Montana's Egg Mountain dig site.
Sounds like a prime expedition spot to me.
Oh hey, that's not far from the dusty patch of paradise we
just came from.
Small world.
Smaller still when the continents were smushed together.
All right.
I saw the original Jurassic Park in theaters.
I was so scared I had to be taken out of the theater when
the T-Rex attacked the car.
Oh!
Hi, business!
Hi!
Oh my gosh.
Did you guys know that, like, the original Jurassic Park
novel?
I haven't read it, but...
It's like... Oh, it's like horror.
Like, it's, like, actually scary.
I remember when Newman from Seinfeld got eaten.
It's super violent.
Spooky.
Alright, so we're going to...
we're sending you I feel like our expedition is underway
let's hope they bring back some great fossils I feel like
these oh we're like dropping cash you see that's going down
keeping an eye on dinosaur welfare is a full-time job and I
don't want your attention stretched thin that's when trouble
starts the Ranger teams can handle it, but they'll need to
be assigned to Ranger posts to guide their patrols.
Let's build some posts and get those Rangers to work.
Okay.
Like when I expect like a dinosaur dig site expedition, I
don't know why I expect it to be like millions of dollars,
you know?
I don't know.
All right, Ranger posts.
Why is that guy there?
Make sure the Ranger posts cover any dinosaurs that you want
your Rangers to keep an eye on.
on during their patrols.
These guys need watching.
These guys need...
Um...
Need, uh...
Surveillance.
This is a path.
Yeah, this is a good place, actually, to put it.
That might be a good...
Oh, Ranger Team.
Oh, yeah.
Require status check.
Reducing guest appointment.
There's no guests here.
What's wrong with you guys?
What's happened to you?
What's wrong with you?
Are you okay?
No ailment data.
A being influenza!
Oh no, I hope not.
Some digs start out self-financed.
Alright, what are you?
I won't let me click on him still.
Noisy.
Just yelling because you feel like it.
Oh,
someone's going in.
Oh, they're both going in.
Big car.
Vroom, vroom.
Little car.
Vroom.
Where are you going?
All right, Ranger team.
Can I see with their eyes?
Can I see the POV?
How do I see it from their POV?
It's their only guests, I wonder.
Possess them.
Two environmental issues.
Wait, make sure all Gala Mimus.
Oh, that's what these guys are!
Oh!
Wait.
Oh, wait.
No.
I didn't even notice.
who guys were here.
I'm so sorry.
I was like, wait a second.
I don't even know these guys were here.
My bad.
We need more Rangers.
Um.
Where would be a good place though?
You can't just put it in the middle of their exhibit, right?
Like, that's crazy.
Galamitos.
yeah direct control you get the car pov but i went like
through their eyeballs you know what i mean oh you can okay
let's do right here that should cut this should cover the
entirety looking good now just assign ranger teams to those
posts and you're set yep are not the only animals that this
client cares about.
So, while we have some time, please ensure that the other
dinosaurs here are comfortable.
I am.
I'm taking care of them.
Wait for Ranger Team Patrols to perform status checks.
85% comfort.
What's your comfort like?
60%!
It's not good!
You need more ground nut.
They love this.
Alright.
A little bit more even.
Okay, wetland.
We'll put the wetland over here.
Oh, whoops.
Grass.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Bog and bog, bog, bog.
Oh, wow.
Wait, let's do some marsh too.
Ooh.
Cypress.
Oh, not good.
Wait, they don't like it.
More bog.
More.
Okay.
That's good.
They're happy.
Uh, thriving even.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, uh, let me click on.
on you.
Comfort 100%.
Not heal.
Missing ground leaf.
He's coming right for me!
Might be the greatest POV ever!
Yeah, just strutting around.
downtown.
Look at them claws.
Oh, he's so cute.
Wait, wait, please, please.
Oh, oh my god.
So cute.
Oh, so cute.
They're so... That looks like... Reminds me of my cat.
Okay, ground leaf.
Oh, wait.
ground leaf ground leaf leafy climbers what about this
matches what they have so oh near the more wetland no one's
gonna want to visit these sites if they can't see the
dinosaurs look this isn't my area of expertise but the math
is simple enough.
Impressive prehistoric animals plus well-placed viewing
galleries equals more guests.
Take those guests and subtract their spending money, and
that equals a very happy Cabot Fitch, huh?
How's that for showing you working out?
The point is, always make sure an enclosure has good
dinosaur visibility if we're to make this a sustainable
endeavor.
A well-positioned viewing building is worth its weight in,
well, concrete and reinforced glass.
Wow, I know, beautiful creature.
What did that guy say?
Oh, the viewing.
Viewing gallery.
Oh, Jurassic World, Jurassic Park, Texacana, Europa, Asia.
Let's do Jurassic Park.
We have everything else themed, oh my gosh, look how cute it
is.
Look, it says Jurassic Park on it!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
You guys know that the Jurassic Park River ride, like the
iconic Jurassic Park ride, the one at Universal Orlando, is
closed at the moment.
They closed it recently.
It's going to be closed like the whole year.
But some people were worried that, or rather speculating,
some worry, that it would be copying how the Jurassic Park
ride is in Universal Hollywood, which got turned into a
Jurassic World ride.
But no, they're just updating it and keeping it.
Jurassic Park.
So it's, I wonder what will be getting an upgrade.
Okay.
So, it's very exciting.
It's not going to be Jurassic World.
It will be Jurassic Park still.
Yeah, so if you want to ride the Jurassic Park River ride,
you can't right now.
But, you know, hopefully when it comes back, it looks really
good, you know.
As a Hollywood native, the change was sad.
I don't like it very much either.
I don't know a ton about it.
But I know that, like, one thing that I...
am a huge fan of is like atmosphere and like you know i'm so
sick of screens and i know a lot of people shared that kind
of sentiment too and they added like screens and stuff to
the ride and it's like i guess kind of cool because you see
like the mosasaurus and stuff swimming around but i'm like
boo no no screen so lame give me animatronics i don't care
how I would rather see something physical than watch TV.
If you're looking for first person mode, check left side
menu.
It's the second button from the bottom.
Oh, I see it!
Thank you!
I see it!
You know, dinosaurs are related to birds.
I wonder what kind of dinosaur Doki Bird or Kiara would have
been.
Probably Trudon or Spinosaurus.
Well, I don't know.
Is Phoenix technically We don't Is a Phoenix a descendant?
Okay, let's see.
Construct at least two.
Oh, we gotta Get a second one.
Oh, right here.
Here too.
Uh It's not enclosure.
What is it under?
Oh my god, noisy.
That's food.
Uh, what was it under?
Oh, here we go.
Doki is a tomato.
So true!
Where is the path?
Oh,
I can only go so far.
It's kind of ASMR.
Nice.
Ladies and gentlemen, we have added a new viewing gallery.
Ready for you.
team make it back all right did they uh find anything good
where did you guys come from use the science center to
extract genetic information from the fossils they bring back
this is a task best done by scientists skilled in genetics
and anything not rich in genetic information could still
make us rich in petty cash so don't be shy about selling
things either
hello it's me hello Oh, it's me, the evil twin with the
goatee.
What the heck?
Why are they, like, doing that?
Why are they...
You, I'm, yeah, I'm you, but cooler.
Are there people here, too?
Oh my gosh, they're different even!
Oh, wait.
yeah they're different whoa where did you guys come from how
did you guys get into the park I don't remember opening it
up okay first-person view select a start
location whoa oh my gosh I can actually go in here
Whoa!
Oh, there's someone.
There's like a person over there.
During most of your tour, the appropriate information will
be automatically selected and displayed for you.
Simply touch the area of the screen displaying the
appropriate icon.
Whoa!
This is so awesome.
And you can hide the UI even too.
That's so nice.
Toggle highlight.
Ow!
Cool!
I can't I can't see where the dinos are and I can zoom
This is so cool This is so cool This is one of the largest
ornitha mime and dinosaurs This is really cool Oh look
there's people here Who are you Who are you guys Where do
you guys come from And then then then they're gone.
They're ghosts.
Just like me.
It looks so cool.
It looks so good.
I like how my park is half a star.
Oh, are you enjoying the park today?
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
Yes!
Oh!
Where does he poop from?
Oh my god, the real experience!
Oh, look, you can shift to high speed.
Wait, what did I do?
Oh, you can pause if you want to get like a photo!
Cool!
That's so cool.
Light off.
Oh!
Life, death, life, death, life, death, life, death.
Wait.
This is awesome.
I see no pooper!
How do you do it?
Look how cinematic this is.
Control low view.
Oh my god.
I'm sneaking around in the...
in the facility.
Ooh!
High speed.
Oh, it's just me running.
this is so awesome okay we're back to uh we're researching
so i can sell this oh and then research oh not hybrids uh
wait she this wait how do i do it Increase genome of
myasura.
Begin extracting genome data from the fossil.
Do I click on the fossil?
Is that what it was?
This one?
Oh, I guess so.
Oh, begin task.
Okay.
While we're laying the foundation of the project, let's
build a hatchery.
Genome soldiers.
Can't breed dinosaurs without hatching a few eggs, right?
A hatchery.
So true.
So we gotta make a hatchery.
Uh.
It says place in the highlighted area, but...
Oh, I can rotate it.
Okay, here we go.
I was gonna say.
This seems like kind of silly.
No?
Incorrectly aligned.
It has to be this way!
Okay.
What?
Has to be in the fence.
Oh, oh, it's one of these types of buildings.
Oh, okay, okay.
Wow.
So that they can, like, go in and do their thing.
Okay, okay.
Oh, so I guess this really is the myasaurus.
Maybe?
Okay.
Oh, fair.
fancy path.
Everything that is a official business gets a fancy path.
Not long now until the genome is done extracting.
What's that old saying?
A watched pod of Dino DNA never boils.
There's people!
People coming into my park!
Welcome!
Welcome to my park!
Oh, you work here.
Everybody works here.
Where's the customers?
Everybody's everybody works here we had two customers and
then the the ones that we hired to look like customers wait
a second but that was definitely a family walking no
everybody's going into this building oh no no these people
are definitely customers oops all actors oh
guys it's not just me
me unless they learned from the best what kind of park are
you running here we gotta make sure that people feel on
their toes what if there's a what if there's a breach you
know they got to feel ready.
How many people have you killed so far, Minty?
Have you named any dinosaurs after Metal Gear characters?
I don't think I can kill anyone in the tutorial.
Dang.
Thank you for streaming this, your dino-induced joy is
taking me back to my childhood dreams of becoming a
paleontologist.
PS Breaker Lake this Friday, so proud of you.
I'll be cheering my Eiffel Heart out during the stream.
Thank you, part-time!
Thank you!
Well, it's mostly just you.
standards to Jurassic Park level too.
Neat.
So funny.
Wait, we're at 69.
Nice.
Out of 70%.
How do I get to 70?
Unless we're just waiting.
Oh, maybe.
Okay, it has like a little countdown.
So I'm guessing that will get us to 70%.
So now we just kind of chill for two minutes.
Mayasaurus.
So cute.
I rate five-star Minto Park.
Thank you, because currently we have half a star.
Oh, everyone hates us.
It's funny because...
the newest Jurassic World movie that's the only one I've
seen of like the Jurassic World series but the newest one is
about how like people don't want to coexist with the
dinosaurs anymore it's so sad and they're like nobody goes
to the Jurassic parks anymore because they're bored of
seeing the dinosaurs and I'm like I don't think that's a
thing people go to zoos I love game did you also watch also
watch watch Jurassic World in theaters when you were a kid
too no
I didn't yeah people don't get bored of animals right
especially if they're dinosaurs I'm just kind of like it
seems like a silly premise to be honest but bored of
dinosaurs I don't think it's possible
Jurassic timeline, dinosaurs have only been reintroduced to
the modern population for 30 years.
I don't think people would get bored in 30 years.
People still like the Beatles.
It's been a hundred years.
So, I think, not the TikTok attention span.
No!
It really wasn't, oh wait, it wasn't really a good movie.
I think that part of it was silly, but I enjoyed the rest of
the movie.
I thought it was fine.
I just, um...
Now that you can exert more control over embryonic hormones,
it's time to synthesize your first male myasura.
I'm creating men.
Just think.
Generations of dinosaurs engineered to be female, and now
we're purposefully unshackling them.
Incredible.
I'm literally God right now.
Synthesize a batch of Mayasora in the Hatchery.
Synthesize a dinosaur.
We need Snips, snails, and puppy dog tails, and that's how
you create a male!
Oh.
Begin the task!
oh my god i can only hope that all the consequences of this
are are being considered my guy is so traumatized of course
but yeah i do love to hope we are considering every outcome
in this research your concern is understandable but
unfounded unfounded geez what a thing to say My concern has
a rock-solid foundation of experience.
You know, I've seen profits put before science.
I've seen rapid progress, and the excitement around that
eclipse any caution.
I want to see him come out.
Not unfounded.
Yes, I misspoke.
Your experience is evident, but we are not biosin, doctor.
We are not in-gen.
Try to see this work with fresh eyes, optimistic eyes.
Well, I'm very optimistic.
so let's keep on going i think it's kind of i'm never gonna
be a fan of more outgoing costs but yeah he did almost die
we're gonna need scientists with skills in welfare to
actually get incubation
going there was a time where there were ghost hunting shows
everywhere now not so much i hope People aren't bored of
ghosts.
You guys aren't bored of ghosts, are you?
I do worry if ghosts are out of fashion.
Sometimes.
I think maybe ghosts are...
Maybe people don't care about a ghost anymore.
Have you seen this before?
That's a corny thing!
Never out of fashion?
You think so?
Spooky around.
I hope so.
Fatal Frame Remake will save ghosts.
Hire scientists with a combined total of welfare.
Ooh, alright.
Ooh, we got some new people.
Welfare.
What was it?
Combined of...
Five?
Was that it?
Yes, so we need to hire two people.
Jamie, thank you!
Ghost rights have come a long way.
and hunting them isn't as accepted as it used to be.
Oh, I was like, why am I getting hunted?
I was thinking like with a gun.
Like I'm like I'm a meat, a deer, deer meat.
Ghosts are eternal!
Yeah!
I mean, until I...
Until I...
Uh...
Um, you know, find my find find my peace and then i move on
i hope i reincarnate as as ketsuko atlas
no peace ever all right i think mariam looks a little
freaked her eyes do not show like Juan here, she's got a
gaze that's like, yeah.
Dinosaurs don't scare me.
Elizabeth, she looks nice.
But Miriam looks really scared.
I don't think she'll serve.
Oh, wait, I have to hire.
No, we could hire Hashim.
And then...
Okay, let's incubate those eggs.
Let's...
Gotta love the hatchery, right?
Amazing building.
But I did.
Wait, but I need Welfare of Five.
Hold on.
Incubate.
Wait.
Did it work?
Yes.
Ready for incubation.
Forge in it.
Resilient, nocturnal, tolerant.
Oh, look at the little heart.
So cute.
We can make our own.
Oh, we're getting the best one, it seems.
Skiddish.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Wait, what am I doing?
Oh, mail!
Mail, mail, mail.
Ew.
Do I do all three of them?
Or just the one?
Did they say?
Oh, I have to...
Do two of them, I think.
Incubate one male, one female.
Okay, okay.
So it is one male, one female.
Okay, that's what I thought.
We'll do the one without genetic traits because we don't
want them to be skittish.
That sucks.
Welfare.
Ah, there we go.
Oh, we did only have to get the one guy.
Yippee!
Oh, hello there.
History.
Repeating yourself, I see.
Hey, tell me.
Did meddling in nature work out well the first time?
time are you talking to me i'm just doing my job i didn't
play i didn't build this place oh my god all right ready
when you are okay release the new dinosaurs release oh are
they gonna be babies oh my god they're so curious look oh
they're so cute Look at all that goo!
It never gets any less magical, does it?
Those are some beautiful animals.
And note how the male and female Mayasura have different
patterning too.
Yeah, cool.
Dymorphism in prehistoric animals.
And given how rare males are in the wild, I can't believe...
I suspect we still have so much to discover.
They got Jeff Goldblum for so much of this game.
And this is just a start.
So, let's get those Mayasura comfortable.
Truly, I thought they only had him for the trailer.
I didn't think that he was going to be like a character, you
know?
Happy to see Minto playing snubbed strategy game of the
year.
It's not an impersonation.
No, no, it's him.
Also, Fokuro, happy birthday!
I decree ghosts are still pretty cool.
We can take you!
Take it, thank you!
Alright, let's build this environment.
We need more ground fiber.
Calamites!
Ho!
And...
Fibrous lobe plants!
Ho!
That should be good.
I should be pretty happy now.
And we want them to be observed, do we not?
Okay, now we need to check our Mayasara's breeding potential
and compatibility.
Oh,
you have ways of assessing their breeding capabilities,
their fertility.
Oh, yes, there are chemical markers, but honestly, you can
tell everything you need to just by observing my man's
living the dream.
Isn't there a fallout shelter like this?
charge here but do I actually have to answer that no no you
do not now eventually you do plan to have breeding in your
breeding program right I'll work on it yeah yes yes we do
but dinosaurs need an appropriate nest first replicating the
natural conditions these animals need is what sets this
research apart They're so loud.
Holy cow.
Replicating nature.
No doubt this will go completely according to plan.
Wait, everything is just average or poor.
It does.
Construct a medium nesting area.
Restroom coverage attracts more of the...
Wait, I'm sorry.
The people want to watch them go to the bathroom?
Or do they mean in the park?
it should have been me not him it's not fair
oh let's also put a ranger post in here
because it seems like these guys need to be watched
uh what was it oh enclosure this medium nesting area
we'll do it we'll do a natural looking one wait what's this
one look like what does it look like oh that's kind of funky
oh wait I just realized I had one in here already oops wait
destroy sorry why did it okay never mind refund give me my
money back what about the dino dino poop where did they do
it the world is their toilet Guys, if we start running on
all fours again, we could be the same way.
The world could be our toilet.
Now don't get too excited in here.
Some of you guys are probably like...
You know what?
I'm convinced, but...
$50,000!
Holy moly.
Can I rotate this?
Yeah, here we go.
We went on some privacy to nest.
Like back here.
The conditions are right and the dinosaurs are happy.
Now all we can do is wait.
Hey, hope I didn't miss the main attraction.
Oh, uh, no.
Hello.
I'm going to first person.
Are you with the thing group?
To watch.
No.
Where are my manners?
I'm Isaac Clement.
Hi, Isaac.
Great to meet you.
I do a lot of work with the entertainment sector, and they
are very interested in this project of yours.
They guys are smart enough to use toilet.
She could be.
So I have to see this for myself.
So, but it's all good.
I'll be patient.
Hey, patience.
That's a refreshing thing to see.
You know, if only those folks that preceded you had waited
longer and planned more, maybe decided not to play with the
genetic foundations of life, with all the grace of a kid
baking a cake for the first time.
And by that, I mean you got to admire their ambition, but my
God, the mess.
Who's going to go into the love nest?
Can you feel the love tonight?
Here in the Lovedness There's just one guy in this whole
cage Everybody wants him Can you feel...
Where's our guy?
A love tonight He's so far away from the breathing mess.
Oh, he's chomping on that.
Oh, what?
We got eggs.
Did I miss something?
You take care of the dinosaurs and they do what comes
naturally.
I can't wait for what comes next.
Wait, how did that happen?
This seems like a good chance to talk about contracts.
How did that happen?
up on the side to build your reputation with the industry
sectors we've got eggs bring extra cash while you're at it
here let's get you started with one now eggs found eggs
found whoa research positive temper temperament at the
science center complete an expedition clear expedition I
want my guy to come home.
So we're now waiting for the juvenile to emerge from the
nest.
It should take about one minute.
It should take one minute for this guy to be born.
Life will find a way.
Yeah, they grow up so fast.
Oh, they are so loud.
They're so freaking noisy.
These guys.
Wait, are you guys enjoying the park?
Our stars are going up.
It's not just a half anymore.
It's three-fourths star.
It's three.
Oh my gosh.
It's three-quarters of a star!
We're almost to one-star park!
Profit per minute.
Wait, three issues reported.
We have a guest count of 171.
I don't see the issue.
Number of naturally bred animals.
Uh, it's about to be one.
It's about to be one whole guy.
In 45 seconds.
Ooh, let's go!
Still kind of bad though.
No, no.
Can you drop?
I can't even pick up the guests.
I think.
Hold on.
I'm gonna select them.
No!
It's so lame.
You know what I could do though.
What if I just...
Be free!
Dinosaur threat!
Danger to guests.
It's an herbivore.
He's fine.
They are really big, though.
He doesn't even care.
Movement in the nest!
Life is about to find a way out of...
They really are holding on to that friend.
They're like, life will find a way, and that's our
catchphrase forever.
Okay.
No one cares about the dinosaur.
can i undo oh oh little baby juvenile dinosaurs created the
old-fashioned way how far they've come no longer man-made
assets that test the limits of what science can or should do
but animals naturally bred animals wow fascinating so
fascinating and possibly um cataclysmic i'm I'm wildly
curious to find out.
Wow, Cabot Jr. You actually did it by recreating natural
conditions, no less.
This could be just the thing to give dinosaurs a foothold in
challenging environments.
He's running!
Wait, I should fix the...
I should fix...
I feel like I'm staring at history in the making.
And it is adorable.
Oh, wait.
Is someone trying to leave?
Oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
They found out.
full disclosure i've already named them cabot jr so make
sure you get their best side i renamed him let's be honest
that's any side right that's the expedition team here's our
capture team oh the people are running standing by go go get
him go go get him i think it's just the one guy yeah go get
him
My stars?
Look, I don't think...
Look, it's going up, actually.
Incredible.
No, he's gonna fall into there!
Okay, good.
Oh, he's gonna drown?
Uh-oh.
Uh, I think we need to get him out of there.
How do I do it?
Can you, um, get him?
How do I do it again?
See, this is a good...
This is me trying to figure out how to do this.
Uh...
I think he's gonna drown.
Oh, transport, maybe.
Ah, here we go, here we go.
And put it back in there.
I think that's our only guy who escaped.
Yeah, he's probably back.
Did that cost us money?
Was it fun to see them be free?
Yeah.
Where's our baby?
There he is!
Oh, so cute!
Minto Jr. Wait, I want to take a picture of you.
What does this mean?
Oh, I guess it's just whatever I'm monitoring.
No.
Is he back?
Oh, there.
Wait, I want to see him getting dangled.
It's quite possibly the funniest visual ever.
Yeah, it's real wet cat energy, for real.
It's so funny.
It's so awesome.
All right, select the Ranger team.
Enter photo mode.
Oh, here we go.
I'm taking direct control and I'm entering aim mode.
Oh, there he goes.
Oh, there he is.
Wait,
wait.
I don't have anything.
Is it because I'm in streamer mode?
That's so sad.
Wait, this is cool that you can like either let them do the
stuff themselves or like do it you know.
What a photo.
Oh, I'm printing out a copy of that one for my wallet.
They grow up so fast.
What a photo indeed.
So awesome.
I wish I could save these for myself.
Oh, wow, that's a really good one.
Like, do you guys see?
I'm seeing...
There he is!
Head out of frame.
The kind of like the difference between these guys and the
Aguanathon.
head shape is okay you can you can do your thing the guy is
just driving in the water okay we need to make sure that our
guests have a good view of these little miracles too ah yes
the three most important days in any life the day you're
born the day you die and the day the viewing gallery opens
yes the day the viewing gallery opens not allowed not is
there like a place that they want me to it doesn't seem like
it okay why is it not allowed oh there we go um that would
be a good place oh it shows you like the view you can see
wait that's so cool oh wow so like here is a good one it
covers a good range i'd say not allowed not allowed denied
this game is fancy ensure the juvenile is visible from a
viewing gallery wait oh oh the juvenile is unwell that's the
trouble with having an undeveloped immune system I guess
good Lord it's Cabot Jr. no it's a Mito Jr shut the hell up
you've got to do something Doc it doesn't seem serious to my
eyes but it does need investigating we'll need a paleo
medical facility to do so you can choose an mbu team and
ride alongside them or give them a task to diagnose whatever
is ailing that juvenile let's find out what's wrong as soon
as possible okay yeah minto jr needs a better rest um all
right construct a paleo medical facility we'll do Jurassic
Park version um where do they want want me to put it.
Oh, can I just put it anywhere?
It's kind of, this place is huge.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, they're just letting me build it anywhere I want it.
Okay, cool.
That's nice.
Uh, hold on.
Rotate.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, not you.
Oh, well, that's fine.
Um.
Oh, there we go.
Uh.
It's a little crowded.
but hmm maybe we'll do it over here
and we need a generator do we have a generator close by no
I'm understanding how the game is working I'm starting to
understand okay so it's like lopsided and it's bothering me
but there's nothing we could do okay Okay, and a generator.
Which, I think the most confusing thing for me is finding...
Whoops.
Is finding where...
Oh, here's power.
Generator.
You know what I mean?
Like, finding where things go.
Like, where I need to...
Where I can get things...
Yeah, but...
We're getting an ad task.
Do it.
Uh...
Add the task.
Do the thing.
Add...
Direct control.
Wee woo!
Sorry.
Excuse me.
It's a medical emergency.
Uh oh.
Wee woo!
Ouch!
Wait, can I get over there?
Uh, wait, where am I?
Wait, woo!
Where am I?
Uh-oh.
Um, can I... Oh, it's like really rocky.
Uh, we might have to take the long way.
Oh wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, we could go, we could take
a shortcut.
Wait, woo!
Uh, it just lags a little bit when I play this game.
like this, but...
Is this it?
Yes.
Meow.
My little guy.
Medical scanner.
Wait.
Medical scan.
Medical... do the thing.
How do I scan?
Aim mode.
Yes.
Medical scan.
Oh, I'm doing it myself.
This is kind of cool that you could do it yourself.
We've done the scan.
So what's wrong with my prehistoric little array of
sunshine?
Cool.
Alan's scan.
She's just prepared to play GTA in the future.
Hi, Don.
Thank you.
Hi Don.
Thank you for that, Gareth.
Cure.
The disease must be treated by an MVP.
team medicate I miss well then what am I supposed to do what
do you mean okay hold on let's get out of I keep pressing
space select cap not cap Minto junior and start the research
Rabies?
Oh, no.
Uh...
I thought it was rabies.
As I suspected, not a pleasant illness, but not untreatable
either.
Have your scientists research the cure, then use an MVU team
to deliver that cure by adult.
I don't think...
Sounds like a plan.
You have the symptoms of rabies?
That means it's already too late.
I'll cut.
we got the we got the medication great that's the research
complete okay now let's get that dinosaur cured let's cure
our dino you team to a nearby ranger post stat okay
patrolling mvu teams will automatically scan and diagnose
minor issues major issues well those will call for a trip to
a medical facility right oh wait not you i didn't know you
were there oh Ranger Coast at MVU.
Wow.
So they'll go around and kind of do the work for me.
We love to see you.
What are you doing?
What?
Where'd the last team go?
I drove them in there.
Oh, I mean, they'll just cure rabies.
Easy peasy.
Yeah.
I got this.
I can cure rabies.
using only my pinky toe.
Wasn't...
Oh, this one.
Ranger post.
Okay.
Wait for them to treat Minto Jr. with cryptosporidiosis
medication.
Oh, no!
Crypto!
Our little guy is a crypto bro!
You've done it!
No!
You know, I was worried there for a second, but Cabot Jr. is
completely cured.
Needless to say, uh, thank you.
Really, thank you for taking care of them.
Meme coin.
You're welcome.
I mean, it was really expensive.
Wait a second.
You're kidding.
Is that Bob?
Oh, how I have missed that man.
We worked together for years, Finch.
My name is George.
But Lambert's fine.
Dr. Dua told me about Din.
And about the juveniles.
She suggested the security sector should advise.
A perfect time for you to join us, Mr. Lambert.
It seems that the situation at our Montana site has changed.
The velociraptors are moving closer.
Oh, the carnivores have noticed the human buffet that we've
graciously set up for them.
What a surprise.
Yes, well, we need to return there immediately and handle
the situation.
Back to Montana.
isn't that so exciting
uh okay emergency event oh shoot I think they might be in
trouble
dr. Malcolm is non-stop sass I don't think Jeff Goldblum
ever plays I don't think he acts You know what I mean?
I think that guy just plays himself.
That guy...
And you know what?
It's fine.
That's what everybody wants and expects.
Ah!
He's so cute.
Go!
What are they doing?
Um, the inevitable?
They're all like, they're like the power puff girls.
Wait, is this?
This is also...
Densetsu.
You see, blue is Vicky, green is Mito, and pink is Phoebe!
Densetsu!
I alert people.
Finch, it's time to prove that Din cares about security.
Well, the guests and me need someone to hide.
Build an emergency shelter.
Wait, where did the other guys go?
Oh, Vicky!
Wait, can I name you?
Vick...
Tori Aroman.
My guy's hungry.
Where's the rest of them?
Oh, here you are.
They can wait.
Hold on.
Minto Phantom.
Where'd Phoebe go?
Phoebe.
Yay!
What's going on now?
What am I doing?
construct at least one emergency shelter oh cool all right I
guess that's kind of important huh yeah cool we got
emergency shelter we'll put you all right everybody run run
to here run to right here a fine-looking hidey hole there
hidey hole open up the shelter to put out the alert open up
Raptors can be a tricky target on the best of days.
These guys are not even...
I suggest letting the pros do their thing.
Give the capture team the task to tranquilize those
dinosaurs and put a stop to the rampage.
No.
They're not even going in.
They're just going to tank it.
No sense of urgency.
They're still going.
These guys...
Oh, never mind.
Are they coming closer?
What is it?
Oh, is this a Velociraptor?
Aww, he's so cute!
Reducing guest approval.
These guys don't care either.
The guys we hired.
Okay, order the capture team to tranquilize them.
Oh, but they're just chilling.
Why do we need to do anything?
Oh, no, we could get hookworms.
How do I do this again?
me oh they're on a move again weird looking dog uh let's see
oh closest response uh there we go uh capture team add task
tranquilize cabot finch sounds like jerry from rick and
boardy what if it is it could be
oh oh geez This guy's pretty close in the park.
Did we get the other one?
If I get one guy...
Okay, there...
Oh, nice.
So it is like a...
You do this and then you go do that.
Oh, cool, cool, cool.
Weep, weep.
Weep, weep, weep.
What?
Oh, he's like circling.
Do you see this?
He's circling the area.
Oh, that's crazy.
He's like, I smell people here.
I wonder if they killed anyone.
They ate any guys.
Wait, I want to do it.
Can I do it?
Oh, they got it already.
Right.
Those dinosaurs won't be waking up anytime soon, but we
better have an enclosure ready for when they do.
We do have a half-built enclosure on site that will probably
do the job.
If you can, you know, finish it up.
Okay.
just steal them and then we that's so funny those fences
with a generator if an animal tries to escape it could hurt
itself or even your guests a light shock however will act as
a gentle deterrent yeah listen you can call me paranoid or
more accurately justifiably nervous but i'm telling you
those generators tend to run out of juice at the uh very
worst of times don't we all but no I don't want dinosaurs
getting out either worth making sure that the generators are
in range of a maintenance post so our maintenance team can
keep an eye on them right oh when the enclosure is ready
give the order to transport those sleeping meat eaters into
it I'll leave it in your capable hands okay take as long as
you need but not too long even sleeping
Wait, ah, stop, stop, stop.
Wait, ah, stop.
Undo.
Wait, undo.
No!
It looks ugly!
I messed up.
It won't let me undo.
Okay.
Nice.
One at a time.
Break it!
Oh, you're right.
Yep, I don't care anymore.
So if only a part of the fence is powered, does that mean
the whole thing is powered?
Like I don't need a generator on everything, right?
Oh my gosh, I can't wait to see these guys.
Deliver PB!
Deliver Victoria Roman!
Can I do it?
Or here I go.
Okay, here I go.
Aim mode.
Never
mind.
Never mind.
We do.
Uh...
Where's the...
Where's our last guy?
Oh, here.
Oh, he's alive!
Good work.
Now wait for the delivery to end and confirm they're all
enclosed.
They're so funny when they're just ragdolled in there.
the air Alan and Ellie had a dig site near here in this
scenic patch of Montana's Badlands you know they were
digging for fossilized dinosaurs and now you're containing
living breathing thinking dinosaurs a mere stones throw away
that's mean Wow it's really you know it's poetic in a vague
sort of sense and deeply terrifying in a more specific sort
of sense.
Oh, dang.
I was hoping that I could see it in first person as they get
dropped into the
bank.
Alright, how do you guys like your enclosure, huh?
Aww, so cute!
Oh!
Hi.
Oh.
Poetry.
It rhymes.
you need more uh cover oh holy hell
whoa wow how does this stuff grow here you know like how you
maintain it and then also more prey you want a little goat
make sure to close any shell once you've dealt with the
threat after all guests aren't likely to spend money while
they're busy hunkering down although a bunker gift shop
isn't a bad idea this is closed right I messed it up yeah
it's it's closed I messed it up a little bit but it's fine
wait this is kind of messed up
Are we gonna see nature happen?
Oh, the girls are fighting?
Minto going in for the kill?
Whoa!
Chomping down!
Ah, second goat.
I hear Nihongo.
We can now... Oh, backup generator.
wait what did it say I don't know sorry I didn't read I went
too fast I hear fonts I can't believe I got invited to the
den set to dot a roar live stage I hope nothing goes wrong a
closed shelter nice job dealing with those raptors thank you
vicious and intelligent carnivores don't tend to mix well
with guests hi dippy vicious and intelligent they may be but
those velociraptors deserve as much support as any other
dinosaur agree a feeder that gives them an outlet for their
hunting instinct would be particularly beneficial better the
goats than us is what you mean to say oh i already did this
i already did this oh my god herbivores do not require
feeders to satisfy carnivores and some pisivores?
Is that like a fish?
This is what I do to the three goats that told me to finish
the ritual.
Fish eaters.
Okay, I use context clues.
I'll do another one.
We can add more than one.
Place a live feeder.
Oh, never mind.
It's already.
Make sure your dinosaurs have an average comfort of 95%.
Build a ranger post that can reach the velociraptor.
I feel bad for the poor sucker that has to go in here.
Wait, this is a maintenance post.
Is it the same thing?
Add it to the list.
Ranger post.
Operations.
What's a Ranger post?
Ranger team.
Expedition.
Am I stupid?
Wait, where is it at?
Well, there's this maintenance post.
It's probably fine, though.
When I conned down.
Operations.
I wish to adopt Mindo Jr.
Um...
I mean, we should have a viewing gallery.
I'll do it.
Not allowed.
Wait, oh, she is rage baiting me.
Ranger is next to the goat.
Wait.
Oh my god.
I, I seriously, you guys, I see.
I actually didn't see it.
I'm sorry.
I wasn't even trying to be stupid.
Those raptors will actually be boosting the sights of the
year.
And more appeal means more guests.
So it's good news in my book.
Guests will actually need to be able to see the raptors to
be impressed by them.
But that's why we build viewing galleries, right?
Yeah, I already did it.
Dinosaur appeal is great.
But dinosaur visibility is what will actually sell tickets.
Rocky, thank you so much.
Improving visibility with attractions.
great thank you yeah important step if we actually want to
make a profit here and you do want to make a profit right
really i'd rather like to revisit our chrythosaurus they
needed males in the herd to thrive and that's exactly what
we can provide them with thank you for the very much thank
you to begin synthesis we will need an expedition center
everyone we're playing dinosaurs
We have processed the fossils in the Science Center.
We can synthesize the mails in a hatchery.
Um...
I think that guy just went after our rangers!
Take over Nyongyan!
Thank you!
No, I will thank you!
All right, construct the operational hatchery.
Uh...
Okay, hold on.
Like I said, I said this before, did I not?
That I was like, there's so many things I have to, like,
remember.
Hatchery.
Also, my camera, like, went crazy.
Wait.
Flip around.
Flip it around.
Making me...
Like, here?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, wait.
Sorry, not Velocity.
Raptor.
That would have been awkward, huh?
Phil, thank you so much for the podcast.
Get in!
Not the Raptors.
I caught myself.
Oh my gosh.
This building is like crazy stupid, though.
Okay, there we go.
Boyfect.
In the pathway.
Do-do-do-do.
Construct an Operational Expedition Center.
This one.
This can go anywhere.
So we'll put it right here.
Wait, does this need a path?
Yes.
Pathway connects to you.
I wish I could curb it more, you know.
Ends up being a little like that.
But it is what it is.
It's fine.
The Tenzetsu Raptor art Increase the genome
Research Is it Where is our guy?
What's he under?
Under this one, no?
Chung Kingosaurus I'm done Who the heck is Chung
King-a-saurus?
I must look this guy up right now.
Thank you for the content.
Chung-king.
I spat literally.
Chung-king-a-saurus.
I need to see what he looks like right now.
He looks...
like like if a if a stegosaurus and ankylosaurus were like
similar big chungus am I in the right place to do this
increase the genome from our gods where I'm lost actually oh
here they are where's our you poor you're Corey, Corey, I
can't say this guy's name.
So this is the big chungus from which all others descend.
Looking for food.
Family tree.
Fertility.
Contraceptives!
Oh my god!
A breeding heat map!
Oh!
Tori in the house source.
Yeah, so true.
So we need to do genome.
Synthesize.
Can I do it in here?
No.
Wait, VU genome library.
Here we go, here we go.
Begin task?
Oh, I need more scientists here.
Alright.
Alright, they're putting us...
They're like no more...
handholding now you you know you have to know how to do this
you have to know how to do this so we need genetics so puppy
puppy is our girl and ban ban actually well Isabella is more
expensive than bin but she's more well-rounded so we'll go
with Isabella
Do I need to do the expedition first?
Let me see.
Oh, it may be.
Oh, it may be like this.
Oh.
Oh, but it's...
We needed to hire these guys anyway.
Okay, okay.
Oh, my gosh.
It's like so much.
Take me to Egg Mountain.
All right.
They'll be back in one minute.
I'll just uh chill
We're chilling
Guys our park is one star A little bit more Our profits went
way down when the velociraptor attack happened Oh sorry Yeah
see our profit our income but then we're back We are so back
video we are so back oh you okay they're fine why
are these guys these guys are walking in the closest group i
have you ever heard of personal space like what is this
you're literally stepping on her toes you are clipping into
her feet my god dinosaur integration network really good
friends let's go into the wow this park is like really
beautiful if nothing else that's what I'm saying like if you
had a Jurassic park in an area that looked like this this is
just like a national park you know like it doesn't even need
to be
where's our guys uh oh maybe our viewing area sucks I hear
the oh oh they're trying to oh Oh
my...
Hello?
I feel like the Rangers need some more protection.
During most of your tour, the appropriate information will
be automatically selected and displayed for you.
Simply touch the area of the screen displaying the
appropriate icon.
There's a guy.
Ah!
Boat!
Where'd the goat go?
Poor goat.
Literally here to die.
Oh.
Where?
Where are you pointing at?
What do you see?
I see a goat.
There he is.
Uh.
Are velociraptors in this exhibit?
The appropriate information will be automatically selected
and displayed for you.
Simply touch the area of the screen displaying the
appropriate icons I
hear them okay uh r for highlight oh we're missing all the
action there's two of them oh there's guys over here where
were you they're all behind the rocks wait this sucks during
most of your tour I'll just climb it.
I keep trying to press space to jump, you know?
Keep electrical panel clear at all times.
Yes.
Good... Oh, they're...
They're going off the path a little bit.
Why are you doing that?
Yes.
Very good.
Can I go in...
Okay.
Dang it.
I thought I'd be able to sneak in there.
Here I go!
Where's my velociraptors?
Oh.
Look how cute!
We should, we, we could get rid of the rocks, you know.
We could probably change the environment so it's easier to
see.
Hi Vicky!
Hi Peabee!
Mysterious, fourth member.
Where is a Minto?
Minto!
So perfect.
Lord Finger!
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my god, the sound is annoying.
Alright, we did the complete.
We can sell.
And then we can do this.
in.
Do I have enough?
Yes.
Start.
Alright.
We are creating males again.
Thanks for playing Jurassic World Evolution 3, even though I
played a lot of 1 and 2, but haven't had a chance to pick 3
up.
3 yet, so it's cool to see gameplay.
For those who have played 1 or 2...
We are so close to providing those animals with what they
need.
Keep up your excellent work.
Thank you!
We are synthesizing, incubating, and releasing.
Synthesize!
Modify Genome.
I can make them...
Random.
Whitgreen.
Poiple.
Blank.
Oh, I thought this was like a...
You can...
Upload your own pattern.
That would be so funny.
Random.
What does this mean?
Hmm, interesting.
Begin task.
Start the task.
We are synthesizing.
The survival rate is only 75%.
Yeah, it's all my face.
It would be so fun if it were, like, you know.
One genetic.
Resilient.
Ooh, yeah, we'll take that.
Nocturnal and social.
I guess we should do.
Do they want...
All three?
Why can't...
Oh, insufficient skill.
Okay, hold on.
We gotta hire more people, I think.
I don't remember what it said we needed, but Michelle has
tons of welfare.
I think it was welfare, actually, no?
Dino-itasha.
Exactly!
In the future, animals will have ads on them in zoos.
You know how sometimes people will like die their dogs pink
instead instead they'll put ads on the animals
okay here we go here we go I don't think we need more
desired population 4 we could probably get away with 2 right
like probably
that's messed up I know it is.
All right.
Incubating males in 30 seconds.
The men will drop in 30 seconds.
Campaigns for 1 and 2 are a little bit different because of
the story narrations, but gameplay-wise, Evolution 3 seems
like overall improvement with more things to play with.
Oh, that's nice.
Miss Cheetah, brought to you by Spectrum.
Blazing fast internet.
Internet almost as fast as...
Or... Internet faster than this cheetah.
Re-dee-su!
Oh, why are the trees like that?
Oh
He's moonwalking you did it I did it happy they're thriving
and it's all thanks to your hard work Well done with males
in the herd.
We are only a well-placed nest away from helping these
animals start a new lineage gay it's not an objective that i
will set but i will always support breeding dinosaurs
wherever possible this is what we could evolve to look like
going on all fours really great but maybe it's time we take
as much care of our bottom line you see our guests need
caring for just as much as our animals they need hotels to
sleep in restrooms A comfortable sight draws in more guests.
There's sand everywhere.
They go home.
I'm especially a people with spending money person.
There were guests.
Oh, yeah.
Time to...
Oh, a hotel?
Small hotels provide accommodation for guests and provide
close distance dinosaur visibility.
Small shopping amenity.
All right.
I'll give you a bathroom, little people.
You get one as a treat.
I love the announcement.
Ladies, I'm with when nature calls.
Ladies and gentlemen, we opened a new attraction.
Please peruse our bathroom.
Accommodation rating.
Hell, I think we could do even more.
bathrooms even one right here crazy I know we should be yes
to dinosaurs what else you want a small hotel oh wow oh my
god you get to see in the middle of the park you get the
restroom view Look at there's a pool on the top!
Oh my god, whoever's driving that car.
Oh, I think you couldn't see it.
My head was blocking the way, but they were being nuts.
We'll give them a fancy path.
Ladies and gentlemen, for your comfort, we've increased the
hotel.
Looking good so far.
FYI, we've got number crunchers behind-the-scenes collecting
info on the site's appeal how guests are feeling and my
favorite bit our amenity sales take a look i'm looking
income per minute 11 our economy is three oh those amenity
sales could be a lot less red how sites like this one make
money is pretty straightforward see If we have incredible
animals on site and the guests can see them, then we'll sell
plenty of entry tickets.
And as long as we keep our guests comfortable and make sure
they approve of what we're doing, we'll sell even more entry
tickets.
Yeah, we're almost two stars!
That's when we hit them with some excellent food, drinks,
and shopping amenities to really bump up our income.
As we seem to be lacking in the amenities department right
now, we should really get that fixed.
More food!
more you know i created din to support dinosaurs and bring
people joy oh here we go and there's nothing more joyful
than good food good drinks and reasonably priced merchandise
oh think of the site's profits as a measurement of joy i'll
put it all over here by the velocirat oh we can't profits go
up and needless to say that's the direction that profits
should be going in
But you're not shooting in the dark.
Our dated geniuses will show you in real time how different
products or features will impact guest satisfaction.
And how that equals more profit.
Here, here, get your...
Oh, amenities can be configured to sell specific products.
Better than match, the higher its income.
Blab, blab, blab, blab, the business talk, the business
talk.
Um...
What are they doing?
Oh, they're inspecting the small amenity, too.
Okay, and next we do, uh, drinks.
I probably should have put the drinks by the food, but...
Oh, we could still do that.
Uh...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You just walk a little ways away, and you'll get a nice
refresh.
refreshing drink by the Velasa.
Come by!
Velasa...
drank.
The Velasa drank.
And here...
is the...
You could change the drink type so you can.
Change product.
To...
What the heck is a kefir?
It's gonna be energy!
Drink.
Change features.
Claw!
Oh, claw.
Jukebox.
Oh, yeah, baby.
And also...
You're not gonna believe what I found.
Well, okay, my lawyers pointed it out to me, but same thing.
A fish tank.
We have more land than I thought.
I trust it'll be put to good use.
Oh, is it?
That sounds good.
and more revenue wink wink wink oh whoa what just happened
oh my god oh oh yes yes i wasn't paying attention to what he
said yes more room while this particular site is owned by mr
finch i thought it best to still define some specific
targets to work towards hold on i'm busy oh total scientist
skills 50 income per minute five $500,000 per minute number
of animals 50 number of guests 1,000 how expensive are these
tickets that we would with 1,000 guests is we are making
$500,000 I got run over by cute mid but the dinosaurs were
cool and the food was great despite being run over it was a
solid five out of five experience we'll return thank you so
much for your very honest review Um,
the getting run over is definitely in a, it's a perk of our
park.
We definitely advertise as a hands-on experience and a
wheels-on experience.
So I would really appreciate if you could edit your score to
a six out of five.
Thank you.
Remember, satisfying these goals will define this site's
overall park rating.
ratings prove that we can manage sites and make clients
happy we hit two stars which helps me expand din globally
nice let's see hold on i'm working on our velasa drink i
cannot believe the momentum that din has suddenly gained
kira nobody likes it though people don't like it they want
the energy drink i think securing a new site now follow my
advice on increasing our reputation and park ratings, and
our proposition will be irresistible.
Oh, quick.
That way, this is...
You guys, look at this logo.
That's so stinking cute.
Wait, it's sushi right now.
Yummy.
I want sushi.
Sushi bento.
Sounds so yummy.
That's a cute logo.
Filofle wraps.
Oh, I'm hungry.
Guys, I'm kind of hungry.
The conservation sector have asked me to keep an eye on Din
long term.
So consider me an official advisor.
And on that topic, your reputation with the conservation
sector would only improve if we had more naturally bred
dinosaurs on site.
Oh, okay.
Cool.
Um...
We have a whole new area.
but guys i think i'm gonna call it here because i am
starting to get quite hungry so i will go eat i'm a hungry
ghost i'm sorry i'm so hungry but this was fun this was so
fun i hope you guys had fun i i this is there's so much to
do first of all there's like a crazy amount to do but this
is So awesome!
Let's go.
Let's go hang out with a...
This is like our fullest enclosure, so...
Actually, no, we haven't seen Dippy in a while.
Dippy, Dippy.
Dippy, Dippy, Dippy in here.
Whoa!
I like listening to them walk.
This is you and your element.
.
He's swinging that thing.
Oh
Wait wait wait
Oh Thank you, everybody!
Have a good day!
Have a good night!
I'll see you!
Next time!
Thank you!
Eat-a-dash-hi!
Uh,
can you see my eyes?
Can you see me?
I'm still on him!
Oh, wait, I think he's gonna...
I think he's gonna step on us.
Well, oh no, we're getting full tail view right now.
If we looked up, what would we see?